[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of our internal lives consequently when
we have too much stuff it's often
because
we have too much mental clutter and too
many distractions today on the podcast
we're talking about the cluttered mind
with dr amishi ja author of the new book
i'll hold it up for the youtube
viewership here the book is called peak
mind we'll put a link to it in the show
notes as well this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast we're going
to discuss several ways to avoid the
distractions that create psychological
and emotional clutter you can check that
out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements suck
doesn't that feel good there's no
advertisements that's awesome dr john
um thanks for being here thank you so
much what a great book thank you for
writing this book it's amazing and yes
please just make sure you call me amisha
yes
uh well you're a neuroscientist uh we
want to talk to you about cognitive
neuroscience today i want to steer you
in a bunch of different directions but
as you know this is a listener driven
show so we're going to start with our
first question here
from ginger on facebook
what are the best first steps to take to
reduce mental clutter
so so a very broad question here let's
talk about
mental clutter i sort of talked about at
the top of the show here quite often
you know ryan are the minimalists and so
we talk about physical clutter but
that's often a result of what's going on
inside us
so having a cluttered mind can you talk
about what that means to you yeah
absolutely and i love the connection
that you're well at first of all i love
you guys you're awesome oh thank you and
i love the connection that you're making
because you're absolutely right
the physical environment we have is sort
of an outgrowth of what's going on in
the mind and from the neuroscience
perspective there's a lot to say
regarding
mental clutter i think ginger's question
is a great one maybe we can culminate
with the question but i think there's
some sort of groundwork i'd like to lay
so that she can
or they can find out what uh what we're
talking about we even talk about what
mental clutter is yeah so so for me when
i think about it
you know again i study attention i study
working memory i study mindfulness
these are
core or fundamental brain processes
and in my mind when i think about the
term mental clutter
it's essentially
too much stuff happening in the mind
disorganized
and the third i would say and this is a
very important component there's a sense
of overwhelm regarding it it's not like
there's a lot going on and it's a
creative storm happening where you're
just like i just can't get enough of my
mind it's that it's uncomfortable
so then the question becomes and this is
where i think it'll be fun to chat
what causes it why do we have this what
is it about the nature of the mind that
leads us into that space often
and it ends up that these same systems
of attention that i talked about really
relate to not just how the mind operates
but really action and that's why i think
it connects so nicely with what you all
talk about with regard to clutter on our
physical environment yeah
you know it's interesting
one of the biggest takeaways i got from
your book was
uh one of the reasons why our minds are
cluttered is because we're constantly
looking at a screen
and it's funny because i look at i've
always thought of like
watching tv or you know watching a
youtube video or something
as being a passive pretty uh you know
pretty clutter free experience
but after reading your book i'm like oh
wow like the more screens you look at
the more cluttered your mind actually is
you don't give yourself an opportunity
to kind of purge all the thoughts you're
just adding more to it so i think that's
one of the biggest reasons i think for
the mental clutter is a lot of too much
screen time
but of course it it goes back farther
than that as well because even
pre-screens
we
had a lot of mental clutter is that
right yeah i think both are true and it
ends up that they're completely
interactive
so the screens that we're talking about
right now i mean we can't avoid them
right i mean they're they're everywhere
we're not going to throw them away we're
not going to uh remove them entirely
from our lives it actually would reduce
the quality of our life in many ways i
mean you know i couldn't have gotten
here if i didn't have the google maps
for example yeah um and
the question becomes what is happening
to the mind when we are looking at
screens you described it as sort of this
passive maybe even sort of a way to rest
your mind
right but it's not rest it is actually
especially when we think about social
media it is very in a very engaging and
and really mentally consuming activity
if you turn on whatever app and you
notice notifications that's work for
your mind
clicking on each one and taking action
based on it is work for your mind even
seeing updates from somebody where you
don't have to interact is work so all of
those things require this fuel of
attention
and it's also impacting and interacting
with as josh was saying everything
happening internally so it's not passive
in any way it is actually active and
frankly exhausting yeah it's yeah it's
crazy i just never realized that how
it's it's not a break for your mind it
is it's just adding more clutter to it
you know
if i had to give ginger advice i'm not
an expert on this matter so maybe uh you
can either affirm this or give her some
different advice but i really love
just that first technique that you share
in your book with focusing on the breath
and as soon as you find yourself you
know your mind wandering you go back to
the breath that's how they fell asleep
last night oh good so i i'm assuming you
wanted to fall asleep yes exactly
i did i did but yeah i mean i think that
for me was like that's the simplest
advice i've ever heard to kind of start
uh finding a way to like uh just relax
the mind
yeah so it ends up that
even the term relax is a little bit
tricky so so maybe it would be helpful
if i could say a little bit more about
what attention is because if we break
down what attention is then we can start
thinking about really that the real
answers to ginger's question which is
how do we treat this mental resource how
do we
guide control or even as the subtitle of
the book talks about it own our
attention and it's not straightforward
it's not what we think because the
things we default to often aren't
actually helpful
um so so maybe just say i know both of
you are comfortable with the book but
for many that haven't heard about it or
read any of the content in it attention
ends up being not just one thing but
many things right
and one of the very uh fundamental ways
attention works is and i'm glad you did
the breath focus practice because it's
exercising this aspect
i'd like to describe attention as sort
of
really um the success story of the brain
you know oftentimes we complain that our
attention's all over the place we're
distracted we're like we talked about
overwhelmed and cluttered but it really
is successful it we don't have much
happening in the brain right now that
wasn't selected for over thousands and
thousands of years
so just to remember that that what may
feel like a flaw may not be it actually
may be a feature
but one way we can think about attention
and we can really break it down into
three main ways the first is a metaphor
i like to use is like the flashlight
right so we can
direct our attention willfully if we're
in a darkened room just like a
flashlight or in a darkened room
literally a flashlight will save us
it'll help us find our way if we're in a
path uh we can and it gets dark out we
can kind of find our way so what does
that do it kind of
hones in narrows
and illuminates makes more clear a
certain aspect of our physical
environment
and that is something formally called
the brain's orienting system we do that
same thing
internally so we can direct the
flashlight internally so if i have an
idea or a thought or
um
an urge or an impulse that's where the
flashlight's going to be and everything
else in my mind is going to kind of go
quiet
so that way of thinking about attention
is very helpful now there's kind of it
relates to jinger's question in in sort
of one important way so just like an
actual flashlight we can direct it we
can guide it we can point it
uh we can decide you know if i ask you
um you know what did you have for uh
breakfast this morning can you remember
that black coffee
minimalist approach to breakfast
yes so but you weren't probably thinking
about that before i asked you and the
way in which you did that is you guided
the mental flashlight of your attention
to reflect on a memory of this morning
and you pulled it out yeah but now
that's occurring in the present moment
well you're reporting it in the present
moment right right but so then if i if i
um
you know let's say we're thinking about
certain things we're guiding our
attention a certain way
if somebody um claps their hands or a
fire alarm goes off your attention is
surely not going to stay wherever the
flashlight was pointed it's going to get
yanked around by something else let's
make it even more concrete a
notification goes off in your phone even
the illusion of a vibration of your
phone on silent i mean how many of us
have had that experience like oh my gosh
i think i'm getting a text message
that will pull your attention away so
the flashlight not only can we direct it
but it can be yanked around
and that is one of the components that i
think adds to the clutter this notion of
getting
wanting to push it somewhere or direct
it somewhere and getting pulled around
because then it ends up sort of
appearing over and over again in our
conscious experience
um should i go through some of the other
ways of thinking about attention okay so
so the other way we can think about
attention is almost the exact opposite
as this narrowing crisp fine grain
flashlight almost you can get it to the
point where it's like a laser beam we
can focus it so exquisitely but
just like your cat playing around you
know you move that laser bean around
it's going to get it's going to get
yanked around by certain kinds of mental
content
so the second way we pay attention is
something called the alerting system
and
it really the term really gives it away
it's what we get alerted to so that that
siren i was describing we know what that
means usually if even if we hear it
outside uh it's like okay something's up
right we don't know exactly what's up
probably something not very good
uh but we know something's up if you're
driving down the road or walking down
the road and you see a flashing yellow
light usually by let's say a
construction site or a school zone or
something
you know what that feels like right it's
you're not there pointing the flashlight
of attention you're kind of broad
receptive
you're
alert and watchful but you don't
necessarily know what's gonna happen
so it's almost like a caution in the
mind that
is broad and um
not selective and really cares about
what's going on right now
so that's another way going back to
ginger's question that our attention can
actually
become
prone to clutter
because at some moments especially under
stress and when we feel overwhelmed
everything feels like a flashing yellow
light
everything feels like oh my gosh
it leads to something called hyper
vigilance
so you know the first ways our focus is
kind of flittering about the second way
is that we have an overabundance of
alerting which is almost hyper vigilant
and then the third way we pay attention
you know is it's it's
yet again another way we kind of parse
the environment something called
executive control
and that the metaphor i like to use is
like a juggler so really the juggler's
job is to make sure that
all the things that we want to do
meaning our goals in the moment our
particular goal like right now i want to
have a fun conversation with both of you
that's my goal it wouldn't serve me in
this moment to sort of get up and or
just wander around the room i mean i've
got to make sure my goals and my
behavior align moment by moment
and we use that term executive really
like the way that you talk about the
executive of a company sure uh you
aren't going to go in and do each
individual task as a leader or as an
executive but you're going to make sure
that everything that's going on is
aligned with the goals
and this juggler metaphor is helpful
because
it gives you that sense of like it's
dynamic and there's only kind of a
couple balls in the air at the time
you've got to manage all of it
and going again back to ginger's
question it's another way that we can
get clutter because the balls will drop
we will get to the point where we will
forget the goal we will not monitor our
behavior we won't guide our behavior
so that's kind of painting a grim
picture because it's like there's all
these ways we pay attention and there's
all these ways in which we can
contribute to that feeling of overwhelm
in our mind
but we need to understand this so we can
know what we can do about it which leads
me back to your comment regarding the
breath focused practice
because that practice if you remember
back i called it the find your
flashlight practice right
and i did that because um we are
training not just the ability to direct
our flashlight
but to know where it is in any moment
because that's the only way we're gonna
be able to do something if it does get
yanked or if we don't remember where
we're supposed to point it
so i don't know that's sort of a broad
way to get to the point which is that
it's very complicated but in some ways
it gives us the landscape of what our
mind is dealing with
and if we can parse it in this way maybe
we can now take a strategic approach to
training our mind which is sort of the
key of what i'm interested in yeah
ginger i think you'll find value in peak
mine i'm gonna send you a copy of the
book sean if you could reach out to her
i'd appreciate it let's move on to our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com looks like
we have a question here from alexandria
and jackson mississippi i recently
relocated
through the military orders from new
mexico to mississippi i was in a 3-2
with a garage and i'm in a 2-2 apartment
and unfortunately i had over 300 items
that came with me through this move
now i'm stuck
with this super clutter apartment i'm
still living out of boxes i'm trying to
figure out what the best way to get rid
of stuff is
i've noticed that i still have a lot of
emotional connections to a lot of my
physical items i'm having a really hard
time
uh letting go and finding ways to get
rid of the stuff that i already put
apart
and
i just i don't know i just
feel like
i'm stuck and i would love to hear um
what you guys recommend about this with
the emotional attachment
um to everything i have like stuff even
far back from high school and i'm in my
40s all right alexandra so you've moved
to mississippi now amisha let me just
say this real quick the average american
household has
more than 300 000 items in it so she
said she moved there with 300 items
that's one tenth of one percent if my
math is right yeah last time i checked
this is a math podcast right yep spot on
thank you
uh ryan we call him the human abacus
i still can't tell if it's an insult or
a compliment
it's a comp assault
so um
amishi um what we're talking about here
really is the attachment that we have to
our material possessions because let's
be honest if you had 300 things that you
truly disliked and someone else gave
them to you you would easily be able to
get rid of them most likely the problem
is when we assign some sort of meaning
some sort of inherent meaning to our
things we call it sentimentality or
they're sentimental items now well the
only thing the only difference between a
item and a sentimental item is how much
sentimentality we impart
on it and so i would love to talk to you
about this idea of the emotional
connection
that
alexandra has to her stuff because it
doesn't start with the stuff it starts
with what's going on up here in our
heads yeah absolutely i mean i'm just
curious before i give you my take on it
what would you recommend that she does
regarding this sentimentality oh i mean
when i hear her describing her situation
i think about the packing party i did
when i when i first started my whole
minimalist journey i had too much stuff
i didn't know what to do
um i knew i needed to like make some uh
changes and for me
uh it usually takes some kind of i don't
want to say drastic measure but just
something that really helps me change my
state
and we came up with this idea
to pack up everything in my house
so like josh came over and he like
helped me pack up my clothes my
kitchenware my furniture toilet
everything we like even covered up my
furniture and then i unpacked things as
i needed it day by day for three weeks
uh yeah at the end of three weeks i had
this kind of
just a new perspective
on all of these things that i brought
into my life and what kind of value they
were actually adding so when i hear
her question when i hear alexander's
question it just makes me think like
this she's in the perfect spot like
she's she's literally doing a packing
party right now unpacking things as she
needs it
yeah and then the problem she's having
now is at the end of that packing party
whatever duration of time you have now
she has these things and it's like uh oh
i know i'm not actually getting value
from them and so i feel as though
i would benefit by letting them go
however i feel like i can't let them go
because of the emotional attachment
that i have to these things where does
that emotional attachment come from yeah
i mean that's a deep question right i
mean i think that
at the heart of it
this is what gives us meaning in our
lives
right it gives us fulfillment it
connects us to other people
and it ends up in motion is actually
very much intertwined with our attention
because we highlight that aspect of an
experience i mean really what comes
flooding back is probably the memory
of what it was and that's not a bad
thing it's just a matter of whether we
need the material object in order to
enjoy in many cases it really is
enjoying like you said if somebody gave
it to us we wouldn't have the
sentimentality but it was a bad stuff we
probably wouldn't want to keep it either
so if it's emotional um
memories that were traumatic problematic
difficult and we saw that we saw that
seeing them over and over again causes
the eruption of mood states that are
problematic we'd say probably get rid of
this or at least don't leave it out
right so so you know i want to really
honor that there especially as a service
member i think she said she was a
service member you know it means a lot
to have items because they give us the
continuity across different physical
spaces especially as service members
travel from one place
to another the question is just is it
serving you in your life and is the
emotional memory that's being brought
forward is the object necessary to
elicit that emotional memory so so you
know i think you both have talked about
this as well could you take a photograph
of it because you write a little
sentence that would describe the memory
and the happy journey and then let it go
because really what's happening with the
physical clutter again is it's adding to
that sense of overwhelm and
disorganization that will interfere with
the day-to-day operating of your mind
yeah it will
so your your question was really
regarding what is the why does the
emotional stuff happen i can't i can't
quite place what you were asking what is
the source of this because quite often
if i see an item i don't just become
attached to it your average person
doesn't become attached to it there are
people who are stage five hoarders and
that's that's a little bit different but
everyone in the western world for the
most part virtually everyone is a stage
one or stage two hoarder when you look
at the five stages of hoarding and so
we're all inflicted with this it's easy
for us to sort of point and sneer at the
people on our tv screens because they
have things strewn across their floor
but the truth is that all of us impart
some sort of emotional meaning to these
things
and quite often i think the root of it
has to do with because we haven't
identified what enough is
for us
and so we feel as though we have this
sort of plague of more i need more more
and more if i just had that then i'd be
happy if i just had this then i would be
fulfilled if i just had this then i'd be
satisfied and then we get those things
of course they don't make us happy the
objects of our desire quickly become the
objects of our discontent but then we
still don't let go of them because of
that emotional attachment there and so
i'm trying to make this this connection
between
okay
when do we pick up an emotional
attachment to those things i think you
answered that quite often we mistake the
memories
as though they are part of the thing now
they can be triggers for the thing as
you illuminated there but the memory is
not actually in the thing the memories
are always in us so you can do the thing
about journaling or taking a photograph
and then let it go that's right that's
right and also to look carefully at
what's driving
the bigger issue which is
sort of these states of mind that we
often will fall into and uh just uh just
at the beginning of the year now and i
was just thinking about one of the
things i'm noticing brew up as i think
about you know oftentimes we think okay
new year new me and that's a whole it's
actually a great opportunity to do some
of the tips and and advice that you give
as well the when you think about
imparting new habits in your life in
fact if it's exercise routine or
whatever it is you know you're gonna
buy less or whatever it is that you're
gonna do you have to remember the mental
habits that are at play
that you if you don't acknowledge are
probably going to land you right back
where you've been
and one of them is actually something
you just touched on josh which was the
if only kind of mental habit right
and so what is that if only notion it's
it's essentially what we'd call kind of
technically a contingent reality like
x then y and and then you know this kind
of this gets it's so that's what i love
about what you both talk about often is
that it just quickly gets us into the
deepest spaces of the human experience
and so this notion of a contingent
reality is something that
in some sense is tied to our
our humanness
because
it's the journey moment by moment of our
lives so you know in the book i talk a
lot about a a solution to a lot of the
issues that can be described as mental
clutter are definitely tied to our
physical environment uh mindfulness
training yeah and one of the things that
mindfulness training is talking about is
an acknowledging of what is happening
moment by moment
without sort of an elaborating on it and
without a reaction to it um
yeah it's almost like the mindfulness
training helps you uh yes to guide that
flashlight a little bit better you
talked about like the flashing yellow
lights and how easy our attention is
taking away it helps your attention to
not be swept away as easily
it's more than that though right it's
more than the for sure all three of
those systems the flashlight something i
call the floodlight the alerting system
and then the juggler it exercises all of
those and we should definitely provide
people with some opportunity to
understand what this is a little bit
more but mindfulness sort of
fundamentally is i think so connected to
the minimalist approach yeah because
it's taking it very granular it's really
taking experience in life moment by
moment
so
again we're gonna now tur completely go
into a different direction if we move
here but i don't know if we're staying
with the question alexandra asked i do
want to talk to you more about
mindfulness in a moment so let's do that
uh when we get to the lightning round
here let's let's see do we have anything
in the live stream any questions right
now
we have one question from alex
in a corporate world where you were half
excuse me in a corporate world where you
have to show proof on anything and we're
constantly bombarded with emails instant
messages calls and video calls how would
you approach this topic
um so yeah
here's the thing about being
constantly bombarded
what we're talking about here is the the
it's the floodlight and you don't have
an opportunity for the flashlight in a
way right let me ask you this are there
certain savants of living though that uh
through mindfulness training etc have um
are able to sort of ignore those alarms
in a way that the average person like me
and ryan are not able to
oh
um
probably not um
and that's just because of our hard
wiring yeah and i would i would say it's
not necessarily having anything to do
with the floodlight it really is the
same flashlight approach
because it serves us to be able to
flip our attention to whatever it is
that may be calling on us
and a work email in some sense
especially if it's from somebody
consequential like a you know supervisor
or something it's almost like you've got
a spear that's going to be coming your
way right from our ancient ancestors so
that what it creates in our mind and in
our body is very similar to that notion
of threat
so whatever way our attention system
responds is plugging into something that
has been evolutionarily baked in oh wow
and so there's nothing sort of
problematic with that happening in fact
you know a lot of people will say well
isn't our attention span shrinking like
aren't we now just terribly unable to
pay attention and no our attention
system is not shrinking there's nothing
different about the attention that it
was at least in the 50 or 60 years that
we've been able to track it in the
laboratory attention spans are not
shrinking okay but our experience of the
crisis of attention is is real and i
think what's been described in this
question
really typifies that it's like there's
too much stuff it's flooding at me i
can't manage it how do i help myself and
the ignoring aspect is what i'm kind of
picking up on on what you said
ignoring is actually another very very
mentally energetically
costly thing to do
it's not actually disregarding with a
neutrality it's putting energy into
suppressing that
and so it takes just as much energy to
pay attention to something and engage
with it as it does to say pay attention
to this and then don't engage with it oh
wow so knowing that is very helpful
because you're like if you say i'm just
gonna push that away what are you
pushing away oh that thing okay what are
you pushing away that thing every time
you have to say to yourself the thing
you're pushing away you're actually
interacting with it in some way mentally
yeah so so here's the thing it's not
about not having the flood of stuff
that's the nature of life but how can we
manage our
space the way we operate in a manner
that is
not going to spend out that attentional
fuel more than it needs to
so for example even if you need to have
all your tabs open for some period of
time because there may be some emergent
crises
you need to be responsive in a very time
sensitive manner do that but any time
you don't need to be
having all the tabs notifications cell
phone on every browser open don't do
that
and a simple way to say it is mono task
don't multitask
because it ends up that multitasking
which is essentially what we're putting
ourselves through we're not
we're calling it multitasking but it's
actually not multitasking
it's something called task switching
right right so that flashlight is now in
this email now we're pulling it away
putting it to the text message bringing
it back reading this thing so what we're
doing is is engaging disengaging moving
and switching where we operate every
time we have to make a switch
we have to kind of recalibrate the
entirety of the brain which is sounds
weird but it's it's true it's like you
can think of the mind as a
studio apartment you know as a limited
space there's a limited amount of stuff
and if i'm making a a big meal i'm going
to configure the apartment very
differently than if i'm going to sleep
so that rearranging is what we're doing
every time we make a switch that seems
pretty costly it's so costly so so if
you mono task essentially you're you've
got the configuration of the mind in
some way just like the configuration of
that apartment a part studio apartment
and then you're using it you don't need
to spend out those extra switches so
that's a simple one meaning simple to
say not always simple to do but know
that it's beneficial it's not actually a
sign of of honor or success to put
yourself in a position where you've got
to try to attend to multiple things at
once because you can't yeah yeah
shout out to our patrons thank you so
much for the live stream questions i
know we got a bunch more we'll address
those on the maximal episode this week
oh by the way alexandra i want to send
you a copy of our book love people use
things i think you'll find
men's help in two of the chapters in
particular we have so it's this
relationship book one of the chapters is
our relationship with our stuff and the
other one is our relationship with
ourselves we even talk about meditation
in that chapter as well so
podcast john if you could reach out to
alexandra let her get a copy of love
people use things if you want the book
book we're happy to send that to you or
the e-book or the audiobook whatever
you'd like ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
questions you can text your comments and
questions to area code 937-202-4654
yes indeed now amisha this is where we
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response not really we monitor on a bit
and what happens podcast sean tweezes
out something makes it pithy and
beautiful we call them minimal maxims by
the way you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place now it's
minimalmaxims.com
hey alabama looks like jen has a
question for us
i want to relax at the end of the day
with something that doesn't involve a
screen but i don't have the energy for
hobbies that i enjoy how do you mentally
switch off without feeling like you've
wasted your free time
i have some epic for you i'd love to
unpack it with a mishi here so so this
is just uh i think this is something
that ryan came up with years ago and now
i'm just i'm repurposing it
a mind is a terrible thing to clutter
you know we hear the old adage i think
it was like one of those don't just say
no commercials a mind is a terrible
thing to waste but one way that we waste
it is by cluttering it now you've
already talked about all these things
that sort of suck up our attention and
there are many of them are unwelcome
things and i've i've
seen and heard you talk about also how
we're essentially wasting at least half
of our lives because our attention is so
wasted with all of this sort of mental
clutter
yeah i mean
uh the the statistic is 50 of our waking
moments our attention is not in the task
at hand so whatever it is that we think
we're supposed to be doing we're
hijacked away from it
and
in many ways it's completely inefficient
right because if you're doing something
put your mind there
one of the reasons people don't tend to
do that is because they don't know where
their attention is
and so my pithy answer would be pay
attention to your attention because
that's going to be the way to get back
on track when you need it most oh yes
man spitting bars over here
what do you got for us nicodemus oh a
quiet mind is a clutter-free mind so
when i hear the question that jen is
asking
um you know she's like how do i feel
like i don't waste my time but you know
paying attention to your attention
having a mindfulness practice um having
a quiet mind that's not a waste of time
yeah at all i think it also kind of
depends on what you want to pay
attention to as well
i heard uh naval ravicon he was talking
about how if um you brought an alien to
earth and he witnessed like your average
cubicle worker in a day and they do like
their eight hours of work in a cubicle
on a computer screen and you know it's
chaotic and spreadsheets and all these
things and they go home and they're
playing video games and they're getting
pure joy out of that they wouldn't be
able to the alien may not be able to
tell what is work and what is play
and it all a lot of that has to do with
what we want to focus our attention on
in a way is there any research behind
that because sometimes it feels like
drudgery to do the certain things that
we don't want to do or being forced to
do and it's harder to pay attention to
that
but then when we put ourselves in a play
state or a a focused state one might
call a flow state
it it feels
a lot more effortless
and it almost feels as though it's
easier to to maintain one's attention in
that setting yeah i mean there's what
you're describing is that that resisting
mind in some sense right we're resisting
the requirements of the moment
and when we do that when we experience
something where we feel like this is
unsatisfactory or i don't want this to
happen and oftentimes it happens with
many aspects of our work you know i mean
i love what i do but if i have to look
at budget sheets for hours on end i
don't love that right that's not that's
not fun science stuff that's just like
work
and so you know when i realized that
that's happening what i want to do
initially the urge maybe pull away from
this don't do this
what is that what is that thought that
is a form of mental clutter
so in some sense what happens is the
thought arises it proliferates a whole
bunch of other thoughts
and then what happens now all of a
sudden
there's so much thinking happening that
there's no actual energy or attention
left to do the thing i need to do
so i've spent so much of my time and
energy elaborating concepts creating
alternate realities simulating a reality
in which i'm not doing the thing i need
to do
that's disadvantaging my ability to get
the thing done how could i have stopped
any of that like how could i have saved
myself what could have ended up being a
couple of hours of just being like i
hate that i have to do this right
well first of all is to catch it sooner
it's like yes amishi is resisting the
fact that she's got to do this task that
she doesn't want to do
and allow that feeling instead of
continuing to grow in terms of the
a conceptual uh chain of thoughts that
it that follow
actually sit with the resisting feeling
you know i'm and i've done this where
and i mean usually not in the context of
something like budget sheets but just
like experience the resisting just let
yourself feel that feel it in the body
feel it like in tension in your jaw your
back
and hold it it sounds counterintuitive
but when you have an aversive
feeling or a sense of resistance
if you just allow it to kind of settle
in it will pass away yes because the
goals are the goals and the mind is
aware of what needs to get done
but
you know it's a totally different
approach than fight the fact that you
have to do this
one will be shorter and probably allow
you to get more in touch with yourself
like wow i never noticed that when i get
this
resistant to something i i clinch my jaw
or i tighten my back muscles and not
have spasms at the end of the day it's
not the
nature of the work that's causing the
spasms it's the mental and physical kind
of milieu that you end up proliferating
in your mind right so anyway i think
that that's uh paying attention to the
body in that way can allow the the
difficult emotion to pass away and by
the way then you have all this attention
left to actually probably more
efficiently get the thing you're
resisting done done
that's beautiful yeah amish we got so
much more to talk about
but first uh real quick uh we do a
little segment called right here right
now here's one thing going on in the
life of the minimalist it's a brand new
month right now and ryan and i have this
little thing called the 30-day
minimalism game we have a lot of people
we've had tens of thousands of people
play it because some people don't want
to go all out and do a full packing
party and pretend they're moving with
all 300 000 of their items but people
often say i don't know where to get
started i want to start simplifying my
life i have too much stuff i'm
overwhelmed by it i don't even know what
to do i wonder how this could apply to
mental clutter maybe we can even talk
about that on the maxwell episode this
week but for physical clutter i would
start with something called the 30 day
minimalism game here's how it works you
find a friend a family member a
co-worker an arch nemesis
whomever you'd like you partner up with
someone in the first day of the month
you each get rid of one item so it gets
you started get you that momentum you
need second day of the month two items
third day of the month three items so
forth and so on so as the month
progresses it gets a little more
difficult by day 12 i found that people
started saying uh-oh i have to get rid
of 12 things today and tomorrow i have
to get rid of 13 things now you can bet
whatever you want but a dollar
a lunch a million dollars
whoever goes the longest wins if you
both make it to the end of the month
then you've both won because you've
gotten rid of about 500 items and it's a
really good start and we've had people
continue to play beyond day 30 or day 31
and sometimes i'll start over reset for
the month we've had some people just
keep going and going and going it's day
319 i'm going to get rid of 319 things
today they're counting out paper clips
and so forth anyway we have a a free
calendar you can download the
minimalists.com
resources it's over on our resources
page a bunch of free resources over
there but it's a principal printable
calendar so you can see exactly how many
things you've gotten rid of throughout
the month by the way i still owe josh a
million dollars
yeah that's for something else
hey alabama what else you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi
my name is yarden and i'm calling from
brooklyn new york
i
had an idea uh regarding minimizing baby
stuff
um in regards to a
question that appeared on the parenting
episode
um
i find it
incredibly hard still
to get rid of anything that has my
baby's name on it uh he's almost one
year old
uh but i do find that with time and as
he becomes more ingrained in our lives
it gets easier and i don't feel that i
need to hold on to every single thing
so my idea is that um
in in in line with
the minimalist attitude in general to
revisit things
every few months i kind of take a look
at the things that i've kept around
um cards that we got when he was born
little gifts that we never use stuff
like that and every few months i find
that i can get rid of a couple more
things that don't actually add that much
value or mean that much anymore
so you know it's kind of an ongoing
process it's not a
one-stop shop but it works
hello my name is nadia and i'm from
denver colorado with spring cleaning
around the corner i have a tip to share
on ethical recycling of unwanted
clothing items there's an online
consignment store called thredup where
you can recycle your clothes for cash
credit or donation
one of the best things that we can do
for our planet is to consume less but if
we're going to consume buying second
hand is a great option
so here's how it works you can order a
kit from their website
at www.thredup.com
and that is t-h-r-e-d-u-p
you fill up the box with unwanted
clothing items
and send it off they do all the work
they inspect the clothing they take
pictures and they sell it for you
and you can either get cash back or
credit to their store to use on items
that you may need or you can choose a
charity of your choice to donate your
proceeds to
which is personally my favorite option
and the best part is that whatever
doesn't sell
they will ethically recycle those items
for you they're a great company to
collaborate with with a wonderful
philosophy on making a positive impact
on our planet which is if more people
wore second-hand clothing items that
would mean less waste and if everyone in
the u.s bought just one item used
instead of something new this year it
would save nearly 6 billion pounds of
carbon emissions
all right y'all big thanks to dr amishi
ja for joining us today check out her
new book it's called peak mind we'll put
a link to that in the show notes also
ryan she has her website it's amishi.com
a-m-i-s-h-i
dot-com if you want to keep up with
everything she's doing down there in
miami at the university and in the lab
for added value this week ryan you know
at the end of last year i put out my top
10 albums list yes which had nine albums
on it who's gonna say how many items
were on at this time there were nine
sometimes they're 12
on my top 10 list but
last year was one of the best years for
music in a long time
especially almost like you know 2020
where there was like not a lot of people
they sort of waited to release stuff so
there was like this pent up angst
that created some really um
breakout albums pardon the pun
but anyway one too soon
[Laughter]
one of those albums
was um something i discovered toward the
end of the year it's a guy named mustafa
and the album is called when smoke rises
and the opening track is called stay
alive and the way that i described it on
my year-end list which by the way if you
want to check out all those albums just
the minimalists.com
sound it's a blog post over on our
website but his album it's almost as
though
nick drake
and drake made an album together oh nice
i call it urban alt folk music
and it is so good it's only eight songs
let's check it out man it's minimalist
and it is a masterpiece i think it was
number five on
my year-end what was number one
mike
oh okay yeah it was a good one yeah like
it just i was listening to it all summer
and so yeah you can check out the whole
list though the minimalists.com
sound but in particular check out stay
alive the opening track from windsmoke
rises on mustafa's new album we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like how can i
escape doom scrolling and reduce the
distraction of social media i struggle
to release physical objects without my
brain saying hey you can't let go of
that how do you override your mind's
defensiveness when you really don't need
something anymore and
i'll get into a great flow state working
on something but distractions always
seem to find me how do i deal with
unavoidable interruptions plus a million
more questions for amishi and the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social just danny
unknown emma the immigrant and the rest
of our team i'm joshua fields milburn
reminding you to love people and use
things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it